j'ai eu la chance simplement de
fréquenter Coluche pendant très
longtemps une dizaine d'années j'ai vu
ce que c'était que la célébrité a des
degrés énormes ça ne m'intéresse pas
je reçois maintenant le comédien Gérard
Lanvin pour le goût des autres le film
d'Agnès Jaoui genre bonsoir alors on est
content de vous avoir parce que déjà au
cinéma vous êtes quelqu'un de rare alors
en télévision c'est encore pire non mais
parce que j'aime pas trop expliquer mon
travail je le montre et les débats sur
le métier m'intéressent pas oui mais
nous on vous aime on a envie de vous le
dire
alors le goût des autres donc le film
Daniel Jaoui scénario de jawi et Bacri
alors je connais pas je parle à oui là
excusez-moi je ne se connais pas ni
Bacri j'étais bouleversé bravo j'ai tout
ce que je peux dire j'étais bouleversé
en sortant de ce film ça m'a duré 48
heures l'histoire je crois que c'est un
film qui va avoir un gros succès et
plein de César dans un an voilà si je
voulais leur dire parce que c'est c'est
vraiment un film qui m'a énormément
touché je crois que je suis pas le seul
d'ailleurs parce que beaucoup de gens
autour de moi que ce soit Elisabeth Quin
ou Patrice Karmous qu'ils l'ont vu ont
été aussi très très touchés par ce film
on sort pas indem quoi c'est quelque
chose d'important alors l'histoire en
gros vous voulez raconter je la raconte
raconter la thier non c'est un histoire
c'est simple Castella qui est Bacri qui
est un industriel qui vit avec sa femme
il a un chauffeur qui est shabbat un
garde du corps qui est vous parce que il
doit signer un contrat donc les
assurances demandent qu'ils soient
protégés ils doivent apprendre l'anglais
il rencontre Clara qui est preuve
d'anglais canalvaro et en fait au début
c'est pas très attention à elle et un
jour en allant voir une pièce de théâtre
où joue une de ses nièces il retombe sur
elle qui joue Bérénice c'est très beau
d'ailleurs on s'aperçoit à quel point
Bérénice est un c'est fantastique
et là c'est le choc des mondes c'est à
dire s'ils ont rien à voir ensemble elle
vit dans un milieu culturel de théâtreux
lui il vit dans son monde un peu
difficile quoi et c'est la rédemption
par l'art lui il est rédemption et elle
ce qui est encore plus intéressant dans
le film c'est avec elle commence à
porter un regard plus critique sur son
milieu et chacun prend conscience non
seulement de l'autre mais aussi de son
milieu voilà
vous l'avez très bien et c'est un film
sur le comportement sur les a priori les
préjugés qu'on peut avoir sur les autres
d'où le titre le goût des eaux des
autres le goût d'aller vers les autres
et ce film est et en cela très très beau
parce que justement il prouve que le
comportement peut être différent peut
changer à la suite de rencontres qu'on
peut faire dans la vie oui c'est ça
c'est un film c'est normal enfin c'est
déjà oui bah Chris il se passe pas
énormément de choses la normalité est
passée au scanner ça avance pas vraiment
dans le Sénart à la fin il y a
évidemment une chute mais c'est surtout
du travail d'entomologie c'est un film
effectivement qui combat un peu les
jugements hâtifs les idées préconçues un
film sur la tolérance moi je disais en
sortant que c'est un film antiraciste en
fait anti raciste par rapport aux autres
c'est un film sur la compassion sur la
sur la charité absolument oui c'est
c'est on a envie d'aimer les gens quand
on sort de là c'est génial
on regarde les autres différemment on se
dit dans le fond peut-être que c'est mon
mon caster là ou moi ou ma Clara et on
regarde les gens différemment et vous
vous êtes Moreno dans le signe on vous
êtes le le garde du corps engagé par les
assurances
alors c'est un oui un garde du corps qui
arrive dans une famille finalement parce
que Alain Chabat qui joue le chauffeur
joue aussi le chauffeur de la patronne
de Madame Castella donc c'est un type
qui arrive dans une dans une histoire et
qui doit commencer à s'adapter à cette
histoire et profondément chier parce que
le boulot de garde du corps est très
chiant la police avant il était dans la
police
histoire de la tortue c'est-à-dire que
de tortues
lui il a donné sadem parce qu'il y avait
un gros bonnet voilà c'est un mec qui
est assez définitif sur ces
comportements parce que justement il a
pris des coups il a pris des coups et
notamment dans son boulot il a il a il a
pris des options qui n'étaient pas les
bonnes et c'est fait virer ou enfin
c'est fait virer parce qu'on l'a un peu
poussé dehors et donc il a un
comportement définitif avec la justice
pour lui la justice c'est de la merde
etc et il va être à l'intérieur de ce de
ce film le seul personnage qui ne va pas
changer les deux d'histoire il a beau
aller quelqu'un ça ne va pas lui suffire
et il va il va se refermer et ne va pas
aller jusqu'au bout de cette aventure
qui pourrait le changer et à la fin il
apprend quand même que lui avait quitté
la police le jour où ce gros bonnet
avait été protégé que son son collègue
tortue lui était resté
il trouvait que c'était une trahison et
en fait à la fin tortue arrête le mec
donc en fait est-ce que ça veut pas dire
un peu la morale de la faire qu'il faut
jamais quitter le terrain
et que finalement il faut pas baisser
les bras et que c'est ça que ça veut
dire on peut parce qu'on peut toujours
trouver de bonnes raisons de pas faire
les choses finalement oui sinon vous ne
feriez plus de télé ni moi du cinéma il
faut continuer à se battre il faut pas
attendre que les autres vous aident
c'est un parcours qu'on fait avec sa
mentalité il faut la faire accepter
c'est tout bête mais est-ce que vous
finalement vous avez pas le sentiment un
petit peu de gérer votre carrière un
petit peu comme Moreno gère sa vie
c'est-à-dire de temps en temps vous vous
cassez là-bas à La Baule et puis vous
dites
je m'en vais j'en ai marre le cinéma non
il faut être clair avec ça j'ai fait des
enfants avec une femme que j'aime et des
enfants que j'aime et je veux les
apprendre à ses je veux leur donner la
possibilité de me connaître aussi comme
papa comme homme j'ai cet avantage là
c'est que je suis heureux en famille et
donc je passe beaucoup de temps en
famille parce que ça me correspond et
c'était un désir absolu de ma part les
10 ans que vous êtes partis il y a 10
ans que je suis parti là-bas j'ai des
amis aussi et je me dois de consacrer du
temps à ces gens-là parce que ça c'est
c'est mon équilibre le cinéma prend
beaucoup de temps à un film c'est trois
mois un mois de préparation avant si on
en fait deux parents ça va trois parents
c'est qu'on se fout un peu du reste
quatre parents j'en parle pas alors
évidemment le le résultat des courses
c'est c'est quand vous faites un film
par an si il marche pas vous l'avez vous
le prenez plein de poire et quand vous
en faites quatre vous avez au moins la
possibilité de penser qu'il y en a au
moins deux ou un qui va être retenu mais
est-ce que vous vouliez pas le cinéma
comme une convivial je m'est tombé
dessus par hasard et je l'ai utilisé
comme une combine parce que je veux pas
devenir un fonctionnaire du cinéma si
vous avez quand même un rapport avec le
cinéma un peu on a le sentiment des fois
vous avez peur de vous jeter à l'eau
finalement non j'ai sûrement peur de me
jeter à mais pas en ce qui concerne mon
travail mais c'est vrai que c'est une
combine à partir du moment où je n'ai
pas appris quoi que ce soit pour le
faire j'étais forain j'ai aidé Martin
Lamotte à construire un café théâtre qui
existe une belle fierté d'ailleurs le
Point Virgule et en cela je trouve que
c'est une combine admettons dessus c'est
pas une raison pour la faire mal je la
respecte tout à fait tout à fait après
les spécialistes ou Marche à l'ombre
j'aurais pu être entraîné dans le
tourbillon mais je sais relativiser
c'est à dire c'est pour ça que je dis ça
parce que
comme si vous avez le peur de faire une
énorme carrière à un moment non non j'ai
eu la chance simplement de fréquenter
Coluche pendant très longtemps une
dizaine d'années j'ai vu ce que c'était
que la célébrité a des degrés énormes ça
ne m'intéresse pas moi je veux
simplement être acteur je veux pas être
forcément star c'est un comportement le
star system c'est pas un métier donc je
n'ai pas cette fonction là moi dans ma
tête comme étant le meilleur aussi au
César etc j'ai pas j'ai pas envie de
faire un concours et et moi le le fait
de d'être acteur et si possible un bon
acteur me suffit largement
alors c'est 50 ans
alors il y a un truc très marrant c'est
que j'ai commencé à l'âge de 5 ans à
faire le tour de France en camion avec
votre grand-père qui était forain alors
là en ce moment on a une flopée de gens
qui étaient sur les marchés puis on a
Virginie Ledoyen qui bossait avec son
père
cero qui trait dans la rue quand il
était petit qui nous a raconté ça
l'autre jour Luchini
oui mais enfin il n'était pas forains
finalement c'est un truc que je remarque
c'est des gens qui ont été en contact
très tôt avec la rue avec les avec les
autres gens à donner une
alors vous le déclic c'est quand c'est
deux versions c'est quand vous avez vu
le malade imaginaire avec le père d'un
copain qui jouait dedans ou quand vous
avez vu les valseuses pour le cinéma le
déclic a été les valseuses 100 pour cela
me dire tiens j'ai envie de faire le
métier d'acteur par contre le théâtre
j'avais 10 ou 11 ans c'est ça c'était
Jean Meyer j'avais un copain donc qui
s'appelait Jean-Baptiste Meyer qui était
son fils et qui m'a amené voir son père
jouer un jeudi après-midi
le malade imaginaire et j'ai pu avoir
accès à l'envers du décor et ça ça m'a
fasciné ouais c'est alors à 17 ans bah
vous arrêtez l'école vous travaillez sur
les sur les marchés après votre école à
vous là aussi ça a été plutôt l'époque
où vous vendiez des fringues pour
western house opus a été votre votre
ruban à vous et vous dites d'ailleurs
que les puces c'est une façon pour vous
de vous débarrasser de votre timidité de
vos complexes ça c'est encore une fois
ce contact avec les gens quoi oui
absolument parce que au plus il fallait
des poter à mort et puis pas toujours
des pièces parce qu'on a acheté au kilo
et on à la pièce pas toujours des pièces
excellentes mais qu'il fallait faire
passer pour excellente j'ai dû vous en
êtes vous dites j'ai été vendeur pour
cesser d'avoir peur des gens voilà oui
vous rencontrez mieux vous commencez
vous rencontrez Martin Lamotte aux puces
à Saint-Ouen et puis au début c'est
parce que vous aviez un camion qui vous
ont demandé de non parce que je les
avais vu au café théâtre à l'école et
j'avais trouvé ça formidable et sans
vouloir m'associer à eux bien sûr parce
que il était trop tard ils avaient
construit leur endroit j'avais eu vent
un peu de de cette aventure qu'ils
avaient vécu et ça ça m'intéressait dans
la tête et idéalement une famille comme
ça ça devait être totalement agréable à
fréquenter parce que c'est des gens très
drôles bourré d'humour et puis un jour
je les ai vu effectivement dans mon
stand et on a parlé de ça et comme
Martin m'a dit on s'est fait virer de
Montparnasse parce qu'ils vont
construire des immeubles on va reprendre
une menuiserie dans le Marais est-ce que
tu connais très quelqu'un qui a un
camion j'avais un camion voilà commencer
par votre première pièce c'est la
revanche de Louis ronde j'avoue que je
l'ai pas vu mais tout de suite vous
remplacer tout de suite après vous
remplacez Thierry Lhermitte dans Amour
coquillage et crustacés qui est devenu
les bronzés et puis vous rencontrez
Coluche quoi c'est-à-dire vous jouez
dans Ginette la case avec Renault et
vous n'en parez qu'on ne renon jouer par
rapport avec nous j'ai joué avec Martin
avec Christian Clavier toute l'équipe de
splendide est Coluche et là pendant 2
ans vous devez très pote de Coluche voir
vous le voyez très souvent quoi je veux
dire vous vous le fréquentez vous allez
même dans les bistrots avec un petit
dictaphone pour essayer de récupérer des
oui mais le comptoir pour lui il m'a
pris comme
oreille et c'était bien agréable et
c'est là que vous apercevez donc la
notoriété vous dites la notoriété c'est
atroce il vivait dans un climat
d'agression permanente que nous disait
tout à l'heure c'est-à-dire que là vous
avez vu ce que c'était près d'être star
disons et ça vous a pas tenté
spécialement quoi oui et puis il y a
plein d'exemples qui font vous savez le
comportement qu'on adopte un certain
moment de sa vie il faut regarder les
autres aussi savoir ce qui vous
correspond qu'est-ce qui vous correspond
pas j'ai pas l'intention ni le désir
absolu de me faire arracher ma chemise
dehors j'ai connu l'INO Ventura qui
marchait très très tranquillement dans
la
bonjour monsieur voilà arrivé à 50 ans
je me sens bien dans mes pompes en ayant
adopté cette attitude là alors je vous
fais débuter au cinéma 177 vous n'aurez
pas l'Alsace et la Lorraine vous avez
superbes oui superbe collant blanc avec
une belle poutre apparente et après bon
il y a tous vos films une étrange à
faire moi j'ai beaucoup apprécié avec
mission un tir groupé Marche à l'ombre
les spécialistes on a parlé et puis il y
a eu quand même des problèmes aussi
c'est-à-dire les moins vouloir toi vous
êtes lancé dans la dans la co-écriture
du film mais enfin j'aurais aimé que ce
soit la co-écriture du film c'était pas
avec votre votre Jennifer alors bon
c'était un film d'amitié mais j'ai été
obligé de l'écrire parce que Patrice
Leconte qui était prévu à l'écriture
avec Patrick dewolj non pas trouvé la
solution dans l'écriture moi je m'y suis
parce que fachener me l'a demandé sans
savoir quoi que ce soit là dessus j'ai
quand même rendu 180 pages il m'a dit
c'est formidable j'avais pas de recul je
l'ai cru
ceci dit je complètement ce film parce
que c'est un moment très heureux de ma
vie avec Jennifer et l'autre problème
c'est le louche quoi c'est vous lui avez
consacré trois ans de votre vie j'ai
fait deux films avec lui vous avez fait
il y a des jours et des lunes et la
belle histoire et ça a été enfin la
sortie quoi ça c'est pas ça c'est pas
bien passé puisque quand Chouraqui vous
a voulu vous prendre pour les marmottes
le louche lui a dit prends pas à Lanvin
alors que vous lui avez consacré 3 ans
c'était pas très sympa je vais pas
la merde mais c'est vrai
mais je suis quelqu'un qui dit les
choses parce que je n'ai pas honte à
dire ce que je n'ai pas honte à penser
donc sur le sur le lascar en question
bon j'étais content qu'il vient de me
chercher c'est sûr elle a résultante
parfois forcément convaincu par les
films donc je me suis tiré c'est tout
bête par contre et il ne peut pas me
rapprocher l'ombre d'une
erreur dans mon exactitude quand je
travaille et ce que je n'aime pas c'est
ce venger à ce point là dans mon dos
donc je trouve que le département est un
comportement
parce qu'après le rôle de Jésus dans la
belle histoire là c'était dur un peu
pendant un moment ça c'est clair
heureusement il deux films remarquables
il y a eu le fils préférés de Nicole
Garcia qui est un très très beau film et
puis les marmottes qui a bien marché
aussi donc
c'est l'histoire ancienne vous êtes un
peu déçu quand même par la enfin le côté
famille du cinéma vous y croyez pas trop
vous c'est pour ça que vous êtes plutôt
avec votre vrai famille à La Baule voilà
et puis la famille du cinéma faut pas
compter dessus dans la mesure où aller
s'adapter ses limitée donc il faut pas
se s'adapter à une famille il faut en
connaître plus plutôt plusieurs elles
existent mais c'est c'est ce dont le par
le film Daniel Jaoui d'ailleurs c'est
c'est des chapelles c'est des machins
autant être libre là dedans et pas
s'associer avec ce qui est très bien
dans le film c'est qu'à un moment Clara
la la l'actrice qui donne aussi des
cours d'anglais à un moment elle se rend
compte que son milieu à elle c'est ça
qui est bien dans ce film parce que ce
foot de la gueule de Bacri qui était un
patron de PME c'est facile mais un
moment elle se rend compte que dans son
milieu elle aussi il y a plein de
combines et que son copain ben ils
essayent le petit le petit peintre là il
essaie de vendre des tableaux à Castella
elle dit que c'est un peu malhonnête
quoi donc si c'est la critique et des
deux côté c'est ça qui est bien c'est un
film qui n'est pas comme d'habitude
monodimensionnel quoi absolument très
ouvert
à la fin du film quand même
bien en tous les cas bravo c'est
vraiment je suis ravi de pouvoir le dire
c'est des chances de faire ce boulot
c'est qu'on voit des films comme ça
voilà
c'est des aventures qui arrivent pas
souvent les exactitude à ce moment-là ça
il se trouve que Agnès et Jean-Pierre
sont exacts moi je le suis aussi quelque
part mais malheureusement je n'écris pas
donc des fois je me retrouve des
histoires inexactes mais c'est pas grave
c'est un parcours c'est ça l'acteur bah
oui bien sûr merci en tous les cas à
très bientôt et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de Inna larditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu